[Musique]
le terrorisme ne détruira pas la
république car c'est la république qui
le détruira vive la république et vive
la france
la nation est meurtri mais debout la
nation est uni derrière son président de
la république
[Applaudissements]
la fin du discours de françois hollande
on sait tous levés on sait tous levés
nous l'avons applaudi nous avons chanté
la marseillaise
nous avons tous vécu ensemble ici là-bas
ou à versailles
trois jours après les attentats
sanglants qui ont frappé la capitale
françois hollande exposé aux français et
à leurs représentants réunis en congrès
à versailles
sa réponse politique au terrorisme alors
on prend les décisions qu'on juge les
plus justes
c'est aussi ça qu'on attend du chef de
l'état et à ce moment-là il considérait
c'est une décision juste
alors après on peuvent tous deux visés
comme monter mais à ce moment là on
avait aussi besoin de cela pour lui
l'unité nationale
j'ai été surpris et moi je devais très
très vite monté à la tribune puisque il
y avait d'abord le président république
bruno le roux qui est le patron des
députés socialistes
et puis et puis moi france 8 pour le
groupe quelques accrocs sénat donc ça
laisse aller très très vite messieurs
les présidents le seul premier ministre
madame messieurs les ministres
j'avais un plan mais j'avais pas tout je
n'avais pas écrit parce que ça me
permettait de m'adapter
je me suis dit est-ce que je monte au
créneau sur cette révision qui ne paraît
pas être ce qu'attendent les français
pour le propre sécurité en réalité non
j'ai voulu avoir une position qui soit
bienveillante
le président de la république vous même
d'ailleurs vous nous appelez à cette
unité nationale et c'est important et
c'est une évidence
il s'agit de pouvoir disposer d'âne ou
devant les 348 sénateurs et les 577
députés le chef de l'état leur propose
de réviser la constitution
une décision élaboré en trois jours dans
la plus grande confidentialité
y compris pour le deuxième personnage de
l'état gelé a pris en entrant dans
l'hémicycle de la part du premier
ministre une manière assez sibylline va
y avoir des annonces fortes avec une
révision constitutionnelle
j'ai donc écouté la déchéance de
nationalité ne doit pas avoir pour
résultat de rendre quelqu'un apatrides
ça me semblait partie sur des bases qui
était fragilisée par ce défaut
d'information et d'association au moins
des présidents du parlement
sans consultation des dirigeants
politiques voici donc la réponse de
françois hollande aux attentes à deux
articles pour une révision de la loi
suprême
il s'agit d'introduire dans la
constitution l'état d'urgence et la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux même nés français
il peut y avoir une surprise parce que
c'est une proposition qui jusqu'à
maintenant a été véhiculée par la droite
et même parfois par la droite extrême
donc il prend un peu à contre-pied à la
fois sa majorité mais même l'ensemble
certainement des hommes et des femmes
qui sont réunis devant lui mais qui dans
un premier temps tu s'aperçoivent pas
tout à fait de l'ampleur de ce qui est
proposé par le président sans réelle
justification juridique
une révision qui transforme la
constitution est avant tout un discours
politique l'état d'urgence et la
déchéance de nationalité sont de mesures
déjà présentes dont le droit commun la
classe politique est encore endolori
mais très vite la gauche se réveillent
les réticences s'expriment chez les
écologistes les communistes et même chez
certains socialistes
le débat sera de savoir si quand on a un
binational on est vraiment en français
c'est ce que l'extrême - consorts une
depuis les années ont disons que nous
donc si nous on met le doigt dans cet
engrenage s'arrêtera pas responsables
quand je suis franchement je vous le dis
je ne pensais pas que la gauche serait
capable de faire ça c'est non seulement
insupportable mais c'est indigne de ce
que la gauche a porté pendant tant
d'années
la déchéance de nationalité mesure
hautement symbolique ne passe pas
notamment auprès de la garde des sceaux
à tel point que l'exécutif semble
reculer le 21 décembre christiane
taubira achève une visite officielle à
alger convaincus d'avoir remporté la
bataille
elle laisse volontairement échapper une
confidence sur la réforme
constitutionnelle présenté deux jours
plus tard en conseil des ministres nous
avons mieux trois semaines le débat va
se poursuivre encore un peu sans doute
en france mais je vous indique par
exemple que le projet de révision
constitutionnelle sont représentés ont
concédé
dans deux jours ne retient pas à ces
dispositions 22 au soir je sais quel
sera le lendemain matin dans le texte
qui sera présenté en conseil des
ministres puisque c'est le président de
la république qui me l'apprend que le
texte comprendra la déchéance de
nationalité et que ce qui se dit depuis
alger n'est pas ce qu'il a décidé contre
toute attente le projet de loi sur la
table du conseil des ministres comporte
bien la déchéance de nationalité pour
les binationaux et ce malgré les
protestations de plus en plus vives à
gauche en ne visant que les binationaux
la mesure créerait deux catégories de
français
rompant ainsi le principe d'égalité
mais manuel valls ne bouge pas ce 6
janvier 2016
ils ferment encore la porte à la
déchéance pour tous la france ne peut
pas créer des apatrides c'est à dire des
personnes sans nationalité ça ça n'est
pas possible ça ça ne serait pas
conforme ni à l'image ni aux valeurs ni
surtout aux engagements internationaux
de la france c'est pour ça que nous
n'avions pas retenu l'idée de pouvoir
déchoir tous les français de leur
nationalité je veux être là dessus
extrêmement clair face à
l'intransigeance de l'exécutif
les contestataires hausse le ton
le président de la république voulait
l'unité nationale rue de solférino ce
lundi soir au bureau national du ps
il assiste aux profondes divisions qui
frappe les siens ça fait un mois que ce
débat empoisonne le pays au détriment de
questions essentielles et donc nous
voulons vraiment tourner cette page là
il faut le faire on disons clairement
aux prisons la république les
socialistes ne veulent pas d'eux des
chances de me suis dit on a fait comme
si on découvrait cette hostilité de la
part de toute une série d'élus de femmes
et d'hommes de gauche c'est extrêmement
surprenant parce que pour n'importe quel
observateur c'était évident que la
gauche irait en traînant les pieds au
mieux en bloquant au maximum or pour
l'exécutif il est indispensable de
rassembler une majorité large pour
réviser la constitution
le texte doit être voté dans les mêmes
termes par une majorité des trois
cinquièmes des députés et des sénateurs
le congrès semble s'éloigner de plus en
plus cette idée qui était une idée qui
venait de la droite
la déchéance a été une sorte de bombe à
fragmentation qui a éclaté finalement la
gauche qui finalement a fait émerger ses
divisions jusqu'au départ quand même
d'une figure iconique du gouvernement
qui était madame christiane taubira
clap de fin pour christiane taubira qui
quitte le gouvernement sur un désaccord
profond
au même moment manuel valls auditionné
par les députés fait un premier pas à
l'endroit de sa majorité le gouvernement
a décidé en accord avec le président de
la république de proposer une nouvelle
rédaction
aucune référence à la binationalité ne
figura dans le texte constitutionnel
le premier ministre contraint d'élargir
la déchéance de nationalité à tous les
français refuse pour autant d'engendrer
des apatrides
une équation impossible à résoudre qui
sème la confusion dans les esprits
preuve de la fébrilité ambiante qui
règne face aux questions insistantes des
journalistes le porte parole du
gouvernement perd quelque peu ses moyens
oui ou non dans le texte qui a été
présentée pré présentée ce matin d'un
avant-projet de loi figurent ou non
cette référence à la patrie 12 et
répondre ça veut dire ce n'est pas
tranché ce qui vous est ce que louise
beauté vous pouvez eux aussi de me poser
la question de savoir si ça vous
intéresse de savoir ce que je vous ai
dit ah non mais ça on a bien compris que
sion serait plaint d'une je ne devrais
pas aux 2 apparaît pendant jeu alors on
va se mettre bien d'accord je vous ai
donné l'ensemble de ce qui a été
présenté ce matin ça veut dire c'est pas
tranché encore mais je vous avez bien vu
que tout a été dit
tout a été rappelé non mais c'est votre
problème
je peux me permet d'utiliser les
guillemets puisque voilà est-ce que la
phrase la peine complémentaire emporte
déchéance de nationalité sauf si elle a
pour résultat de rendre la personne
condamnée apatrides est ce que cette
phrase figure ou non dans la vos
convives au procès doit se poser cette
question vous allez la pause et
j'imagine que d'autres la poserons je
vous ai donné l'ensemble des
dispositions qui ont été présentés ce
matin au conseil des ministres
je vous ai répondu je vous ai répondu le
5 février la réforme et enfin examiné à
l'assemblée le scrutin continue de
diviser
je rappelle la discussion du projet de
loi constitutionnelle de protection de
la nation au prix de nombreux compromis
avec les socialistes
mais également avec les députés de
droite le texte est adopté avec 317 voix
pour
il le stigmatise pas les binationaux au
risque de créer des apatrides
le scrutin est clos voici le résultat du
scrutin contre 199
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
oui la copie des trois cinquièmes
l'assemblée l'un sur le gauche et droite
ne correspondait pas aux discours
initial de manuel valls mais que lui
comme chef de gouvernement a voulu
trouver au regard de la responsabilité
qui était la nôtre
la meilleure solution pour avancer y
compris symboliquement sur la déchéance
de nationalité contre le terroriste
voilà donc si la question c'est est ce
qu'il a été obligé d'avancer par rapport
à sa position initiale
oui parce que c'est un homme de dialogue
le sénat acte 2 de la révision
constitutionnelle sur cette révision de
la constitution
il y a aucune volonté au sénat diffère
obstruction doublons simplement un texte
qui porte les valeurs notamment
d'efficacité il n'y a aucune arrière
pensée au sénat aujourd'hui
si le premier ministre pensait avoir
passé le plus dur à l'assemblée
nationale le sénat va pourtant lui
donner du fil à retordre faut convaincre
le parlement
je demande de france et comme le
demandent les français vont se
rassembler ici
la fronde gagne les bons des sénateurs
socialistes
et ici c'est plutôt inhabituel un quart
du groupe s'oppose à la déchéance de
nationalité
peu importe que le premier ministre
vienne en personne tenter de les
convaincre c'est tendu c'était tendu et
compliqué si manuel valls ne se départit
pas de son sourire le dialogue ce temps
avec la majorité sénatoriale de droite
le piège se referme sur le président de
la république et son premier ministre ou
attention la ligne rouge c'est
l'apatridie c'est exactement d'ailleurs
ce qu'avait dit présent de républicains
au congrès comme on avait ouvert le
boulevard
d'abord nous les socialistes à à pouvoir
tordre le bras au président de la
république dans cette volonté que j'ai
rappelé et bien la droite sénatoriale
ici qui fait de la politique
elle fait la politique eh bien elle
s'est engouffrée dans ce boulevard là
pour dire dans ce jeu de la sémantique
et bien nous nous revenons la génèse de
ce que vous voulez françois hollande la
droite va saisir la balle au bond elle
n'a pas envie de sauver le président de
la république sur le terrain sur le
terrain politique il faut pas oublier
qu'on est tout même à un an de
l'élection présidentielle et que donc le
combat politique a commencé
le gouvernement est dans l'impasse les
sénateurs de droite ne veulent pas
d'apatrides un pied-de-nez à l'exécutif
mais également un revers pour nicolas
sarkozy qui avait négocié le compromis
trouvé à l'assemblée nationale y'a pas
de sarkozystes fillonniste
copé east ncaa et miss et tout ça ici à
la conscience sociale le bon sens et le
service de la france vu de l'extérieur
on dit c'est la primaire qu'à polluer le
débat je peux vous assurer que non on ne
retrouve plus justement les lignes de
différence des primaires personne
n'admet devant les caméras l'autre match
qui se joue en coulisses les primaires à
droite le texte qui sort de la
commission des lois au sénat n'est pas
celui que souhaitait le chef de file des
républicains
nicolas sarkozy l'état d'urgence y est
plus encadré la déchéance ne s'applique
qu'aux binationaux
la situation est bloquée pour l'unité
nationale il faudra repasser
[Musique]
le ministre est ce qu'on pensait pouvoir
obtenir un compromis entre les deux
champs au jour tous n'en voulons pas
cette révision constitutionnelle mais
puisqu'il ya débat et ben may débattre
c'est pas ça qui va changer l'état de
sécurité du pays
c'est comme ça mais tout le monde joue
avec ça tout le monde le gouvernement
les partis politiques l'assemblée le
sénat tout le monde joue heydari ça
c'est pas ça sert à rien ça sert à rien
c'est comme ça rayon homme de dialogue
contraint et forcé à l'assemblée
nationale manuel valls va montrer un
tout autre visage dans l'hémicycle de la
haute assemblée et vous le savez
parfaitement car il faut se parler aussi
directement votre proposition ne sera
jamais adopté par une majorité de
députés je serai
je serai donc je serai donc très direct
l'amendement adopté par votre commission
des lois prend le contre-pied du
consensus et je ne vois pas là de
respect de la parole du président de la
république
j'étais étonné très franchement je me
suis dit mais il est fatigué c'est pas
possible il se méprend totalement c'est
pas comme cela que on engage une
discussion surtout avec le sénat et ben
oui il peut être un petit peu énervé et
ben oui il demande un peu de sérénité et
surtout de la solidarité par rapport à
cette majorité sénatoriale qui encore
une fois n'est que dans un jeu de
tactique politiciens tournée vers
l'élection présidentielle
réponse cinglante et immédiate si cette
réforme échoue ce sera simplement parce
qu'elle a été mal préparé mal gérée mal
négocié au départ à l'intérieur de votre
propre parti
j'ai bien vu ce que vous cherchez à
faire avec une nature une attitude un
peu provocatrice
d'abord vous ne pouvez pas vous ne
pouvez pas proclamer votre amour du
bicamérisme tout en nous demandant de
nous aligner sur l'assemblée nationale
ça c'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]
vous n'aurez pas faire un ingrat
monsieur le premier ministre vous
n'aurez pas faire un noeud grave
et puis on fait pression sur nous et au
contraire plus on a envie de résister et
c'est ce que je n'ai pas compris
c'était vraiment une sorte d'erreur de
fautes même et l'exécutif et et est venu
là si j'ose dire dans cette disposition
d'esprit où il fallait mater le sénat
c'était une adresse je crois que j'ai
préféré deuxième discours du premier
ministre parce que on donne pas des
injonctions au parlement essayons
d'avancer
je respecte le vote du sénat je
respecterai les vote du sénat et des
choix mais je veux que ça se fasse en
totale transparence et que nous
puissions ensuite cheminé ensemble
assemblée nationale sénat et
gouvernement quand on crée un apatride
ils restent sur le sol et non seulement
l'apatride mes chers collègues n'est pas
expulsable
et pire encore il bénéficie des droits
très important très protecteur que lui
confère la convention de 54 convention
que nous avons signée et que nous avons
ratifié
donc finalement on se prend les pieds
dans le tapis
c'est vrai que à cette heure on ne voit
pas bien comment on pourrait aller vers
un texte qui puisse devenir également
celui de l'assemblée nationale d'où des
parts menteur constituant et lui les
premiers ministres donc c'est à lui de
trouver des consensus
qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement dans l'instant on veut voir
ce que vous attendez quelque chose
sûrement bien trop mais c'est encore
bien mystérieux je pense que j'ai encore
bien mystérieux cette première journée
de débats au palais du luxembourg se
termine au milieu de la nuit une journée
marquée surtout par à l'affrontement
entre le premier ministre et la droite
sénatoriale excuse quand même supplice
ce jeudi matin peu avant la reprise de
la séance dans les couloirs du sénat
on espère que la nuit a porté conseil
je sais pas si ça se passe au sénat mais
ea type annuel valse découvre les vertus
du dialogue
j'aime bien
moi j'espère encore convaincre le sénat
de bâtir un compromis avec l'assemblée
nationale nous en sommes loin
manuel valls ne croit pas si bien dire
dans l'hémicycle à gauche comme à droite
ils sont bien rares à le soutenir
l'article 2 sur la déchéance de
nationalité continue de diviser
alors pour moi lutter contre le
terrorisme monsieur le premier ministre
c'est donner des moyens à la police à la
justice à l'éducation nationale nous
risquons de moins appréciée si d'autres
pays se mettent à nous renvoyer les
binationaux qu'ils auront déchus de leur
nationalité
la représentation nationale a besoin
donner une image une image au pays
certaines sont ne sont pas favorables
une image de rassemblement cet article 2
c'est un danger pour notre pays c'est un
handicap pour la lutte antiterroriste
c'est irresponsable la france c'est son
honneur ne saurait fabrique et
d'apatrides nous aurions préféré que
dans cet amendement il ya plus d'élément
qui permette de rapprocher les points de
vue ce n'est pas votre choix
l'article de ré écrit par le sénat et
adopté sans surprise pour ne pas créer
des apatrides la déchéance de
nationalité concerne donc exclusivement
les binationaux la version est bien
différente de celle votée par les
députés
un mois plus tôt il y aura le vote
solennel est derrière le vote claudel et
bien il ya la responsabilité de moi même
du président de la république du
président de l'assemblée nationale élu
premier ministre et puis ensuite de nos
collègues
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard le terrorisme
frappe à nouveau en belgique
trois kamikazes se font exploser à
l'aéroport et dans le métro de bruxelles
en pleine heure de pointe dans l'heure
qui suit bruno le roux le patron des
députés socialistes publie sur twitter
ce message attentats terroristes et
protection de notre pays
la droite sénatoriale qui bloque la
révision constitutionnelle est
irresponsable
quelques mots publiés sur la toile alors
que le sénat doit voter solennellement
dans l'après-midi la réforme
constitutionnelle
cet été c'est un moment que j'ai très
mal vécu je me suis dit il dépasse les
frontières et hélas il ya eu en tout cas
au sénat une forme d'indignation
gauche et droite unie dans l'indignation
en des moments pareils utiliser des
arguments de cet acabit là c'est indigne
d'un président de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale on a les dirigeants d'un parti
socialiste qui il est vrai n'existe
quasi plus qu'ils sont dans l'espèce de
provocation permanente il faut que et à
droite et à gauche tout le monde arrête
et petites phrases qui se calme qui se
calme dans l'intérêt des français
l'intérêt du ps tout le monde s'en fout
ce même jour nicolas sarkozy vient
devant les sénateurs les républicains
contre 1 il se range derrière leur avis
je sarkozy un mot sur leurs intérêts
matériels qui a accusé de
dommage l'idée
à nicolas sarkozy qui était relativement
apte à composer a été démentie par sa
base est en tout cas par sa base
sénatoriales
d
dernière étape de ce marathon législatif
à la haute assemblée
le vote solennel après avoir adopté
l'article 1
puis l'article 2 de la réforme les 378
sénateurs doivent se prononcer sur
l'ensemble du texte
mais la fin de partie est déjà connu 176
voix pour cent soixante et une voix
contre 11 abstentions
le sénat adopte sa version de la
révision constitutionnelle
le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
constitutionnelle de protection la
nation maintenant nous avons les bases
pour discuter d'un compromis encore
faut-il que les dés sont deux assemblées
le veulent
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il y à un texte
sur lequel il vient les trois cinquièmes
de la majorité qui s'est exprimée alors
que senna il ya une majorité plus courte
lavours me semble que le point de
négociation doit porter sur le texte qui
a déjà les 3/5 d'une assemblée de part
et d'autre on commence à élaborer les
différents scénarii possibles qu'elle
porte de sortie honorable pour françois
hollande
2010la justice obéir garde au premier
ministre ait fait preuve d'ouverture
à l'abri des caméras les tractations se
poursuivent pour voir si un congrès est
encore envisageable sur le seul article
1 l'état d'urgence ou en incluant
également la réforme du conseil de la
magistrature
le chef de l'état passe une partie du
week-end de pâques à consulter à la
recherche d'un compromis
je dis au président de la république
après le vote du sénat qu'il y avait de
voir la voie normale institutionnels
d'entrer dans un examen du texte du
sénat par l'assemblée nationale
quelle idée singulière d'imaginer qu'ils
auraient eu un conforme en une lecture
ou l'autre était de suspendre parce
qu'au fond la majorité de gauche de
l'assemblée nationale n'était pas en
capacité d'avoir un dialogue sera au
tour notamment la déchéance de
nationalité
j'ai décidé après m'être entretenu avec
les présidents de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat de clore le débat
constitutionnel
quand un moment donné vous voyez que ça
passe pas bah vaut mieux arrêter le
carnage arrêtés nous ridiculiser passer
vite à autre chose et en tous les cas ça
laissera de grosses séquelles je me suis
dit que finalement c'était la seule
décision à prendre
il ya une forme de soulagement parce
qu'on voit bien que on s'empêtre est les
uns dans les autres dans un débat qui
n'avait plus de sens vis-à-vis des
français qui a perdu la politique
les politiciens les représentants de la
nation parce que nos concitoyens qui ont
une défiance vis-à-vis nous eh ben on a
remis une pièce dans la machine
vis-à-vis des populistes et des
extrémistes moi je peux pas m'en
satisfaire
l'émotion rend aveugle cela pourrait
être la conclusion de ce fiasco
politique une révision de la
constitution
cela ne s'improvise pas cela nécessite
de prendre le temps d'une fonction
arbitrale
on est sur des sujets majeurs qu'est ce
qu'un partenaire une nation quel
équilibre car on a très peu parlé mais
d'un sujet très important dans l'état
d'urgence entre sécurité et liberté
c'est un débat éternel mais c'est un
débat essentiel quand on s'engage dans
un tel type de processus avec des
équilibres politiques aussi difficile à
réunir
il vaut mieux avoir réfléchi et réfléchi
deux fois en amont on a l'impression que
ça n'a pas été le cas et que ça a été
fait avec une certaine hâte
la tactique l'emporté sur la stratégie